a news now investigator Vanessa Murphy
has been exposing issues inside Nevada
prisons for nearly a year she has more
about another failure by the Department
of Corrections which has been kept Under
Wraps
there was a bomb scare here in the
downtown Las Vegas area Wednesday
afternoon sources say it was connected
to the prison escapee that he left the
device in his prison cell before he
escaped and an investigator with Nevada
prisons drove it downtown here the
Nevada Department of Corrections
conducted an inventory of the the cell
and there was a briefing at the Marshall
office downtown
during uh during the the investigation
look what they had they saw something
that was suspicious so at an abundance
of caution the lvmpd was notified that
device rendered safe but it's unclear
why it was transported in the first
place Porfirio Duarte Herrera placed a
bomb in a coffee cup at the Luxor in
2007 resulting in a murder he was placed
in this medium security prison which he
escaped from sources say he was last
accounted for Friday evening the
Department of Correction saying staffers
noticed he was missing Tuesday morning
don't be stupid he was captured
Wednesday night on Friday Governor Steve
zisilak announced prison's director
Charles Daniels would step down at his
request the situation with the escaped
inmate is a serious and unacceptable
breach of protocol Southern desert
Correctional Center where the inmate
escaped from is the same prison where
there was a riot in December the
department tried covering it up we
exposed how bad it was after months of
research prison insiders have expressed
concerns about Staffing inmates say
they're not receiving proper Medical
Care their loved ones trying to sound
the alarm about their safety at High
Desert State Prison we've learned about
an inmate's murder earlier this week two
suicides within hours earlier this month
the murder of an inmate by his cellmate
who issued numerous warning signs last
year the Escape just another example of
a department in disarray this cannot
happen again now that bomb scare near
many buildings including Federal
property U.S Marshal Mary Schofield
issuing a statement thanking Metro for
taking steps to ensure the safety of the
courts reporting in downtown Las Vegas
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
the prisons director's resignation is
the second one we've learned about in
recent months after the eight news now
investigators uncovering of that Riot
the prison Warden stepped down